so I wanted to start off initially by
giving everyone a chance to understand
that this panel which was Valentina's
idea and came from the various
experiences that she had had and that
many of my students at Cohen loop have
had with having certain expectations as
aspiring data scientists and being faced
with very different expectations
sometimes of the market based on
differences in what hiring managers and
recruiters tech recruiters and HR
managers are asking for and actually
seeking for the various data science
roles that's part of the reason why
we've invited a panel with very diverse
experiences in technology in academia in
different fields that have come in to
data science or data analysis or data
engineering with the expectation that
they could grow and they could progress
their careers working on data teams or
working individually as data
professionals so I want to start off by
asking the panel or the group as a
initial question that given how much
hype we've lived through and seen with
C++ and PHP and JavaScript being the hot
technologies of the moment now that data
science is kind of one of the it
technology skills or skill sets that is
being hired for particular particularly
here in Berlin I'd like to know how each
of you discovered data science for
industry what got you interested and
what you know now about working in data
science in industry that you didn't know
when you were applying okay I think I
will start so I started out with a
degree in Information Systems which is
computer science and business and it was
very math focused we had a lot of
statistics and I happen to like it a lot
and but it was always not enough for me
to see statistics
in order to to do some analysis past you
had collected some data to get some
insights I was always interested what
you can build product with it using that
methodology and I was very very happy
that I discovered machine learning a
little bit before they hype and I had
courses in university teaching machine
learning it looked more the
old-fashioned way but I found it really
really cool and really interested and I
was actually surprised when I found out
that it can actually make a career with
it and it can do cool stuff and yeah
that's that's how I got interested and I
was lucky to get a job at I say P and
maybe what I know now what I hadn't know
before is the amount of data engineering
you actually have to put into getting
machine learning products to run and you
cannot just apply some fancy method on
some data which it's not there in the in
the normal case and you have to put a
lot of work in it in order to get the
data where you can actually apply what
you want to do in order to get the stuff
done what you want to achieve
I actually don't do data science I'm a
data warehouse engineer but I'm
self-taught so that's kind of related I
first got interested in this topic in my
last semester trimester of roundel
program when we had an SQL course that I
absolutely loved I fell in love with it
and I was like okay I'm definitely going
down that path so let's see what I can
pair it with
so I started googling and then I
discovered wow so I can do Python and
SQL okay what does that mean Google said
data science I like yeah okay let it do
data science then so then after found of
when I where I was doing the SQL and a
lot of projects in SQL a lot of quizzes
I went to Coursera and I did a lot of
projects on Python and then doing data
analysis with Python and then a bunch of
other stuff and then I started applying
for jobs and I got my internship my
first internship as a data engineer and
actually the task was a machine learning
task that I had to do they were very
impressed with my skills even though I
had only applied like a really simple
model on the data that they had sent me
and they were like yeah we want you to
work for us it's an internship I was
like wow my first internship I'll take
it and then after six months of
internship I started applying for junior
roles and I this is where I currently
work at as a junior data warehouse
engineer at window and yeah yeah hi for
me this job as a consultant slash data
analyst for this market driven company
is basically my it's a second career I
work for ten years as a journalist so I
kind of know data science from the data
journalism perspective but only vaguely
I also did my Master's here in Germany
in Environmental Management so you know
there's was some sort of like data
analysis going on there but not that
much at that time during my Master's
here I was working for a software
company and but on the marketing side on
the qualitative side during that time I
was also doing the data science and SQL
course at probably loop so after a few
months I managed to ask them like guys
can you put me in a situation where I
can do a bit of coding and they put me
in with the data science team which was
at that time very small team like only
two people were there and the job was
initially to support the product which
was a chatbot so I learned a lot about
you know and they'll be there learning a
bit of cara's a lot of hyper parameter
tuning that kind of thing and but I to
be honest because my background was not
in computer science and this company had
a lot of coding for production paths
that's some that somewhere where I kind
of like felt a bit out of my depth to be
honest but for other things I was doing
okay yes I think I'm still learning um
but I got a position where the company
the company I work for was looking for a
consultant who has like knowledge of NLP
and you know knows the theories behind
sentiment analysis and all that kind of
thing for me the biggest revelation was
that machine learning or data science is
not exclusively for computing or IT jobs
that it can be applied to different
industries like say journalism or
environment and my thinking is that in
the future I can go to these industries
with this skill set and it would be very
useful so in a nickimja ask me during
this panel is thinking how did I end up
in data science it seems like I can't
even remember so then I was digging back
in my memory and I think it was 2008 I
was starting my PhD and it took me I
forget to three days to figure out how
to load a CSV file into our this was
before Stack Exchange and stuff like
that and then nine years later I got a
job at solando so there's the inspiring
story for you there but just to fill in
a bit so I had a kind of more
traditional sort of academic career but
all during that time that experience of
taking so long to do something that was
so easy just loading a dataset into our
seemed crazy to me and so I just over
the years spent a ton of my time working
on learning how to do software
development and automating a lot of the
sort of processes from statistics class
that weren't actually taught and we're
just really hard to do
and then a couple years ago I actually
was there's a famous data scientist at
Harvard and he has a number of pieces of
software that a lot of people used in my
statistics department and it was kind of
like all that it was just going really
poorly
nobody was maintaining that stuff and it
was always it wasn't backward compatible
it was crashing all the time so I wrote
all these blog posts about how crappy it
was becoming and then he he actually
said well why don't you come and fix it
and so that was the first like full-time
sort of software data science job that I
had that wasn't just academics and then
from that I moved on into my my current
career in solando this is a very long
and windy windy path okay I want to go
back to something that Alena said about
when you started applying and so you
said that when you started applying you
faced a lot of challenges in terms of
preparing and applying for different
roles what did you know what role within
the data science field your skills best
matched when you started applying this
is a general question for everyone no I
had I mean I knew what I didn't want to
do I didn't know how not to do it what
didn't you want to do I didn't want to
do web development yes any web
development yes any web development I
know I've said this before I'm probably
you're tired of hearing this I didn't
like JavaScript so yeah I really liked
SQL and Python and I really wanted to
find something in this direction I
didn't actually know the difference
between a data engineer and a data
scientists before I actually landed my
first internship so I was I was on to
take whatever there was on the market
that could help me grow in this field so
I just
like applied for a number of jobs I
can't count them anymore and then they
just sent me challenges tasks or they
asked me for whiteboard interviews I
have to ask Chris and Mattias because
you both had more academic training
within the data science field before
applying for your first industry jobs
did you also face the whiteboarding
challenges and the take home exercises
and were they as terrifying for you as
they seemed to be for others so I had
this whiteboard interview even though it
was not like mini whiteboard is online
but I was lucky to not had a homework
and I was lucky enough to be no I had
known it before that there would be a
whiteboard interview and I could prepare
so yeah I was happy but there still were
very frightening and I think the hardest
part of an interview I had ever done in
my life so far Chris so I have a
ridiculous answer to this question which
is no I never had to do that because I
had an even remember how many statistics
articles and software packages that I
had developed before and so that I know
I don't know why is the wonder didn't
ask me to do that but I think it was
because I had this track record of
applied work that people could see kind
of unusual perhaps yes oh maybe I also
have an answer for you a question prior
to that if I knew what kind of role I
wanted to apply for I didn't have a name
for this role so I knew I want to apply
machine learning I want to work with a
new state-of-the-art machine learning
models but I didn't know what job
description that was and I looked a lot
and defined data scientist you find
machine learning engineer you find
machine learning researcher you find
data scientist and I found out that
sometimes there the overlap is quite
large there's no textbook definition
when a data scientist or
engineer machine learning research
actually does there's no real consensus
across industry so there was a lot of
work that I needed to do to really
understand the job postings and to
figure out what I would actually do and
sometimes this is really hard because a
lot of job postings are poorly written
and sometimes if the feeling it was
written by somebody that is not from
that field or they're building up a new
department that have no clue what they
actually want to have a want to do and
just really quickly on that doubt that
is very much part of the experience that
I had also right so we just we just have
so many words for the same thing
so is there had looked at data science
jobs sort of over the years but didn't
know if I was qualified for them route
because the just the terminology was
different than I was you students like I
think I know that but I'm not sure yeah
and then sometimes also all old jobs are
get relabeled so like a classical
statistics is now a data scientist so
this is also you suddenly find job
postings that then you think oh I'm not
qualified for it but maybe also
statisticians that would be qualified
also don't find it because probably
nowadays they would also look for data
scientist but a couple of years ago they
might have not so a more general
question might be how do you tell a good
role whether or not you're fully
qualified for it how do you tell a good
description of a data science role from
a poor description of a data science
role this is very difficult you don't
know in advance all the time sometimes
if they're very very generic than the
feeling okay this might not be it
because then they might not have an
understanding what they want to have and
if they're more specific and if I could
relate okay and have an idea of what I
would be actually doing then yeah then
that would be a better posing
the permits like based on the position
in the task I recently had a recruiter
called me recently and I wasn't really
based on his description it was really
difficult to glean what the role is
exactly the it said there she he said
it's a data analyst position okay but
you know beyond that there's not a lot
of information so I asked him okay what
kind of libraries do you use because
that would help me a lot in you know
thinking where you know the company yes
but even then even that he couldn't
really say exactly and you know they
usual find us in sci-fi libraries but he
said there's more so I'm like okay I
really don't know what this position you
know it's all about them what do you
wish the non-specialists knew about data
science or data science roles or tasks
that they don't seem to always Express
in the job descriptions that for me I've
noticed and like it was also what I saw
in my other companies that there's a lot
of like code and code manual labor in
data science stuff that like you really
cannot automate immediately and you need
like people with no um you know with you
know they don't really have to have like
data science experience in my previous
job they just had a factory of students
creating training data and figuring out
the pox on me so these people like they
you know they are not from computer
science they're working students I've
also noticed that like it's got some
jobs that additionally do not require
some data science skill set are now
requiring that but just the basic for
instance in consulting in the in the
past my company had had consulting
positions that we they just asked are
you good at Excel and that's
but now they require the consultants
like to interact with Python scripts
like open a file run it and if there's
an error or they have to know what it is
so that they can talk to the relevant
person so yeah there's a lot of variety
I think in the pipeline that doesn't
really require like PhDs or I think
masters in in machine learning for
people who are trying to figure out how
to navigate the whole HR and getting
passed HR what would you say based on
your varied experience is the best way
to prepare yourself for a role in data
science at different levels what are the
requirements if you had to list them so
I would say first know what you're
applying for what the specific skillset
is that you need as far as you can do
that and out of my perspective is I try
to get practical experience as much in
that field as you can get and if you
haven't and also if if you know that
there could be a whiteboard interview
prepare for it and you can train it and
you can practice this I think this helps
also a lot because if you if you can
practice for something then then you
should do it because people that hire
probably will expect that you practice
it before and you will have a
disadvantage if you don't that would be
my advice even though this process seems
little bit odd that you practice
something that sometimes may be not
related to the things you were going to
be doing on the job but you still need
to practice in order to pass this this
barrier
um yeah so my experience with HR is
pretty various because at some point on
the telephone the HR recruiter asks you
if you know like a like oh if you have
knowledge of a certain tech stack and
they ask you for instance
so have you do you have any experience
with Postgres and I'm like no but I do
with MySQL and then they like seemed
like they make a break in the
conversation and then they repeat the
same question but with different words
like what's your experience with
Postgres and I'm like yeah okay I
already said I don't have an experience
with phone squares but I do with MySQL
and then it's like ah well of course
because they don't know what the
difference texts are right so this is
why they keep asking they like have a
certain number of questions that they
need to ask and they get a yes or no
answer and that's what they are
satisfied with yeah and then about the
whiteboard interview having a first
whiteboard interview with no CEA's
formal background is this curious thing
ever even like preparing for three days
in advance right you don't know what
exactly to prepare so you prepare
everything but of course being there and
having to code in front of other people
while they judge your code and also
keeping in mind that you have to be
verbose about it right and you have to
explain your your process and you have
like to put it into words right you you
you have to think about the technical
concepts that you're using while using
them that's I don't know not very
straightforward in my experience so yeah
do prepare but maybe like don't expect
to be successful from the first time
I've never had a whiteboard interview
I think because I've only applied for
jobs that are basically data analysts
that have very strong business
orientation so my interviews have always
been with the business side I think with
me it helped that I already had projects
and I could I was I've done like a
sentiment analysis and topic modeling at
a professional level even though it was
very simple it meant that I knew their
their business concepts they also asked
me for like market business questions
like you know case analysis and how to
how I can apply machine learning
concepts on it
so that was my experience so I set up
the interview questions with the
recruiters and so I guess from the
perspective or from that perspective
it's very much that in my experience the
recruiters don't have data science
backgrounds they as you were saying they
don't know what any of these things are
so they require the the person who's
coming up with the interview to
basically come up with like a list of
words that they're looking for
right so technologies or methods or
these kind of things and then it's a
matter not so much of I mean if you can
speak in detail about this you need that
for later in the interview but at the
initial HR interview you just need to
know where this is my experience of this
you need to know know that you actually
can talk at least briefly and coherently
about each of those and sort of
demonstrate a bit of experience right so
like I did this with with this tool even
if it's not very in-depth but that's
kind of for the initial HR part of the
process I am interested in how business
knowledge and storytelling and soft
skills that might not necessarily be
related to programming ability
contribute to your confidence and
contribute to your viability as a
candidate for a data role how important
do you think it is especially Chris
you're in a hiring position how
important is it that candidates
understand that their data is not going
to live and die within the data team but
it's eventually going to go out to other
functions and other areas that don't
necessarily know or care about the
algorithms behind this data they just
want a story to be told that's that's
huge so as somebody who manages a team
of people like this and then we have to
communicate what we've done to other
teams who often often cases are sort of
more fashioned soft skilled sort of
background people and don't know
anything about statistics or it could
probably you know would have a hard time
talking about standard deviations or
even knowing what those are that's
that's really huge and actually one
thing that I almost always ask in the
interviews that I do is for people to
actually go through kind of the whole
research project and process that they
go through so like what was the research
question you had why did you have that
question and if it's for a school
project and that's kind of easy and not
that informative right I was told to
have this question but if it's for more
industry project that can often be
really informative right so we
identified this customer problem and so
that this was the data we had and etc
etc and then how do you communicate the
results of your process of the research
you've done is is really really massive
also I would definitely agree so this
was formed for my job posting it was not
the requirement to have storytelling
skills or even visualization skills but
it turns out that this is one of the
most important parts of my work if I
want to get my work recognized because
we working with internal stakeholders
and similarly as to your job they they
have no clue about data science or
statistics or statistical methods and if
you get good visualizations and you have
a good story to tell then you can
convince them that what you build is
actually valuable and they can use it
and hopefully also make money out of it
so that the company profits from
and if that is not possible then
probably your project will die or will
not be continued or they will not really
implement it or say yeah it's nice and
then move on to something else
so this is this is really important
skill that I think really belongs to
true data science role that you can can
do this I know that okay you're your
role because you're a consultant
officially is definitely focused on
visualization storytelling and kind of
client communications but for everyone
else in the group how much do you feel
like data visualization on its own
should be and maybe is or is not treated
as a specialization or an area of
strength and how much is it just assumed
that you will be able to do the
visualizations and put a coherent story
together with the data on top of
cleaning it ensuring that it's valid
having some understanding of how much
confidence you can have in it is
important for my company like I've been
doing this PowerPoint for three weeks
now so he's with the team Soho yeah but
anyway so because that's it's the people
who will you know consume your project
that report are not people with data
science background it's cross-functional
people from the marketing team and from
the business side are also kind of going
to read it so yes it's important to have
this data you know in how presented in a
manner that's you know understandable to
everybody our data scientists are also
required to create this you know
visualization report visualized reports
so oh yes it's pretty important for at
least the consulting side of the company
now in the past like in my other data
science job it wasn't that important but
you have to be able to talk to you know
the other teams because you will have
some needs with them so yeah it's
important to have you know to be able to
explain things in a clear way to other
people who don't have that
we at whim do have actually separate
roles for the visualization person so
I'm more in the background doing the the
ETLs and then there's my colleague who
does the visualization reports for
marketing for finance for whoever needs
them
so i seldomly do reports in tableau
because that's also part of the job
description but yeah like my main focus
is on how to get the data from source to
our main database but yeah my colleague
she's she's the one telling stories to
marketing and finance about what the
data is so bad so my role I think it was
definitely assumed that we could do it
and and our machine learning department
for the business analyst departments I
don't know it might be different but for
our machine learning tasks it's assumed
that you can communicate the results
appropriately how much of that comes up
in the interview process not at all
for me it came up in the interview
process cuz because they made me do a
presentation that was my like my the
technical it was my interview one of the
technical side of the interview Chris I
know you walk people you have people
walk you through their process but does
it include visualization and explanation
of those I guess it doesn't include
visualization but I'll take that but it
does definitely include people
describing their results right so
oftentimes their results will be
something or the research they did is
something that I don't know anything
about and so that's a really great
opportunity to do I understand what
you're talking about in this in this
interview is a good indicator of whether
or not they're gonna be able to convince
other people I guess I'm interested in
how given how much buzz there is around
data science in general and how little
information there tends to be outside of
the PI data community about the
different special specializations how
how easy do you think it is for someone
who's switching fields to break into the
data field in Berlin I'll start then so
I don't think it's that easy
mainly because like Chris and Marcus
said the job descriptions are not very
straightforward so as a newbie trying to
change careers like from a non-technical
to a technical what do you look for you
know because business intelligence
developer data engineering data
warehouse engineering they all like can
require the same set of responsibilities
but not necessarily so where where do
you go looking for that I don't know
it's like I started looking for keywords
okay so I'm using this I have experience
with that maybe I can learn this right
and
yeah start applying to a bunch of jobs
that seemingly have nothing to do have
nothing in common to one another so I
came from the humanities and I thought I
think it was a bit difficult to break
into the IP side of things here in
Germany I also came from the Philippines
so a lot of my you know um credentials
were suspect so but anyway um yeah when
I started with fro in loop it got me to
a point where I could say to the HR of
the software company where I was working
for hey I know this thing actually so
like you know you know give me tasks
that you know that involve these things
and I think that the position really
helped because I learned a lot of
machine learning there I was also able
to implement like a machine learning
project for another company that I was
working for because I was working two
part-time jobs at that time and having
those projects really kind of like
boosted my CV and it allowed me to talk
to recruiters and to in a more
knowledgeable way like sometimes I'm
like way ahead of them because like like
we said they really have the basic
knowledge of what goes on sometimes I'm
a head of them when it comes to like I
know know certain concepts like what
they're looking for so that for me that
I wouldn't have liked I think broken
into it without those factors
so if it's easier cannot tell because I
elect the experience around it so if I
come from a computer science background
I think this helped in order to come
from other backgrounds which is
definitely possible and I see it in my
team we have quite some backgrounds I
don't know if it's easy for them but I
think it might be easier to become to
get into a data role from a different
background than computer science
compared to being becoming software
engineer from a different background I
would say that that raises the question
to me as as to how important additional
learning opportunities or sponsorship or
mentoring availability in a company in a
role might be when you're applying so I
guess I wonder for for each of you I
wonder whether you had any expectation
of receiving either additional learning
opportunities through the job or
mentoring from a manager from a senior
um so I was very clear from the
beginning with every interview I had
that I'm a junior
I need learn I need like upward learning
opportunities and that I expect some
sort of mentorship from my seniors
and almost all of them said yes of
course no problem yes we have a bunch of
seniors that look forward to getting you
started and like teaching you all are
like getting you into the business flow
of course like with most of them the
final part of the interview is like we
really do appreciate your work and your
skills but unfortunately you're not a
culture fit so yeah I think even though
they say they can provide mentorship
they don't actually realize
the importance of being guided like all
on a daily basis or yeah
or like getting mentoring for like
specific tasks that you are responsible
for also both of the companies I think
don't have or don't want to invest in
time training juniors because that's not
bringing any revenue for the company I
don't know but that's super crucial for
juniors like having someone there
[Music]
guiding them or like being available for
answering questions no matter how many
times you ask the same question you know
I think they are willing to provide the
right answer or like to ask in their
turn questions so that you find the
solution yourself right that requires
time patience and not many companies are
willing to invest in that I would highly
recommend not taking a job that wasn't
very explicit about the growth and
learning opportunities that you have so
data science is such a first of all it's
such a complex field that you need to to
build your career you need to be going
deeper and deeper oftentimes and also
the technologies are changing so fast
that you need to be keeping up with that
so if you're the employer doesn't even
conceive of that as an important part of
your work to be deepening your skills
and keeping up with technological change
then I wouldn't want to work for them in
terms of how how did how do you know if
they're kind of right about that so as
you pointed out like everybody always
says that they're you know we want to
mentor you and it's you know this kind
of thing but as as somebody who's kind
of a manager and I guess technically
also a mentor like I just have so many
meetings all day long it's just so busy
right so I try my best but
but I'm limited in my ability to do
that and so what we have that's great at
solando is a lot of explicit learning
opportunities right so like courses that
we run in house or making sure that you
can have a certain percentage of your
work week that's for learning these kind
of things that are much more likely to
actually happen than sort of a vague
promise of mentorship or something that
same in my previous company they also
have like a percentage of your time you
can like do for personal development
like so if you want to do an online
course on company time you can do it for
like an hour every day I think also
companies have to realize that there are
people in there are you know companies
who are like we who want to be mentors
there was a if I hadn't like you know if
I need if I didn't need a full-time job
I would stay in that other company
because there was a woman there who was
like really willing to mentor me and she
wanted that as well and you know we
could do pep we we were doing pair
programming and she was she was very
good at explaining a lot of concepts to
me so that was really cool yeah and so I
think you know companies should also
look on that side when I graduated from
university I was well aware of the lack
of knowledge that I had in the data
science field and when I applied for
jobs I somewhat applied mostly for for
bigger companies or at least I wanted to
to work in a company where I know there
were other data scientists because some
some companies just hired a dead data
scientist and I didn't want to be the
the only one because I wanted to learn I
wanted to see how it's done in theirs in
industry how it's done in practice and
yeah sometimes bigger companies have
have can give you this advantage because
you don't have the the product pressure
immediately hitting you all the time
that they actually can give you learning
opportunities and that they have a big
team of data scientists that you can
work with and collaborate with and learn
from them I wondered how vocal all of
you or most of you were about
seeking mentorship opportunities and
seeking support for your continued
learning when you were applying did that
occur to you is that something you you
asked for explicitly I I did in my
interviews because this was really
important for me
not until you get very beginning but at
some stage in the interview I would say
that this is really important for me
especially because of the field
especially machine learning you go on
vacation and you have three new papers
improving the state of the art and and
some domain and there's learning is
really really essential for me same as
well like I told them like on Mondays I
have to leave early because I have a
Python class so yeah so they they let me
do that and aside from that I've talked
it like the other data scientists and
they are like making me learn are yeah
well it's okay so because the main
language in the company is are like okay
fine yeah I was also very explicit about
being mentored and with like also in my
internship also in my current role I am
very lucky to have a boss that's very
very very patient with me and teaching
me everything he taught himself seven
years ago when he started building the
infrastructure so yeah also like in my
internship whenever I didn't have any
projects to work on my mentor would
suggest like doing a course on Coursera
you know company pays so why not so like
maybe you can do like an course on
algorithms because it's not really your
very best strengths
so yeah what's the top skill that you
think this is a question to everyone
what's the top skill that you think that
your company requires for you to
successfully win a position in data
science and why do you think you were
hired
can I just answer it the other question
really quickly so I had someone who does
interviews usually near the end of the
interview there's like do you have any
questions for us and I am I almost sort
of require that people ask what are the
opportunities that I have to develop my
skills and knowledge right because that
that's just an indication that that
person actually cares about work and
about really kind of driving their
skills forward and those are the sort of
people that I want on my team sorry I
forgot your other question for everyone
else what what do you think you were
hired for what skill specifically do you
think was the deciding factor and your
being hired I think for me it was like
the machine learning background even
though the job is not a traditional data
science I think they want to be able to
you know relieve some of the pressure
from the data scientists are having an
in-house analyst there who could code is
something it's you know valuable to the
team they are also I think there are
also projects in the pipeline for their
clients on NLP I'm not sure where that
will go but I think somebody who has
experience on that was also valuable for
them um I think the best my best skill
that I was hard for was my ability to
learn you think or you know I know so I
don't know but I hope that it was for my
machine learning knowledge and maybe
also for my ability to communicate it
and to talk about what I could do and
what I cannot do
so mine's a little idiosyncratic but
maybe also it has a kernel of generality
to it which is my data science
background and paired also with
knowledge of a non data science field
which is economics not that that is
necessarily general to all the people
but the ability to take to not just be
about data science but also to pair it
with some substantive knowledge in
another field can be really valuable I
think what do you wish that or rather
what's the biggest misconception that
people in business have about what data
science and what data scientists can do
so with his recent AI hype this gets
really intermingled with data science
and suddenly data science can solve
everything and every problem and quickly
and quickly end without data so I think
that's the biggest misconception that
it's not only about the the data science
and the data analysis skill but that
there's this whole strategy that belongs
to it with with around data and the
company people from not from the
business intelligence team think that
when when deploying an algorithm then
suddenly are ranking well like go on top
of the mountain right because you're
like doing data science you're you're
supposed to do that why aren't we
ranking first you know in Google when
looking for apartments what did you do
with the data
I think like the ones that I've seen so
far like they think they have enough
data already and their data is great and
clean but you know there's like a lot of
you know like it's not enough it's not
gonna be enough to what they want us to
do that kind of situation yeah so there
are many big misconceptions but one is
kind of thinking that just having a lot
of data they're just big data well then
we have tons of insights that are in
this huge amount of data but you don't
actually have any variation in the data
right so it's kind of like during the
World Cup sales of World Cup jerseys
like really go up and it's like okay
well sure but we don't have any kind of
variation in that data to really learn
some actionable insights from so that's
a big misconception what do you think
that that lack of specific understanding
about what data science is and what
specializations it encompasses means for
hiring what does that look like in terms
of from your experiences what does that
look like in terms of who gets
interviews and what kind of profiles
seem like they're gonna lead to a team
of data scientists this is a difficult
question so one thing is one
misconception that I have not talked
about before is that you need Superstars
and academics to do data science and I
think that's this is the the major
effect that shows in the hiring process
that I have the feeling that the
companies try to hire the most academic
person that can find the most researchy
person that can find and maybe ignoring
other people that can do the same job
maybe better maybe worse
I don't know without having a proper
process to separate for the real
competencies they want to look for and
not if they just have a PhD or five
research publications in the data field
has anyone else run up against that kind
of expectation that they should have
neither more research or more proof
academic proof of statistics or any
other specific qualifications I wasn't
asked for like any I don't know academic
records or yeah I was just my github
account was always present on my CV and
there I have a couple of projects that I
worked on like including like software
development and data science projects so
our discussions always started from
there right I wasn't asked for like
anything else on top of that like no
statistics no anything of course I'm
also not doing any data science for me
it depends like if it's an issuer person
yes they ask but if it's a the person
who's actually doing that technical work
that's less of an importance than
actually knowing the tasks behind the
job say yeah like for instance I can
talk like they talk more about I here on
what library have you been using what
projects have you done what did you do
to solve these things those were the
questions that they asked more so I was
just gonna ask what you would recommend
because I keep hearing that the projects
that you can demonstrate or talk about
are important whether or not you have
computer science the statistics
economics whatever your background might
be how would you recommend if you have
recommendations for people who are
either self-taught or trying to build up
a github repository of projects that
they can then use to get into a
full-time role so open source in general
and also github like basically totally
changed the trajectory of my life I
would be a more traditional kind of just
weedy academic person now I'm a weedy
data science person and the I guess the
opportunity to build port
leo of work to demonstrate kind of my
skills and also develop those skills
this is really huge and I almost always
look for that in new candidates they
don't look at but also just the for me
it was about being part of this bigger
community of everybody else who was
trying to sort of figure things out and
it's very supportive and contributory
made me want to be part of a community
like this so that was that was a really
big part of it for me
last question before we open it up for
questions from the audience what is the
one thing you would like to see changed
in Berlin about the whole data science
job hiring advertisement process set up
that as it currently exists
so maybe I come back to the point that I
made at the beginning of the discussion
is that companies should get clear about
what they want and what competencies
they want and make them explicit and
then look from there what they can ask
or what they should ask from from the
potential candidates I know that if you
post job posting with data science on it
you probably will be flooded with
applications but still one shouldn't
exclude portions of possible candidates
that might do awesome work I would
suggest the same maybe yeah like I would
like for companies to give more chances
to people with no formal background in
the field but who can demonstrate their
ability to work on projects you know
either
by looking at their github repository or
I don't know making them go through a
challenge or more I would also like for
the interview processes to change a bit
I've had way too many experiences
negative experiences when when
interviewing when in the final phase
after waiting for two weeks for an
answer I just got a reply saying none of
the challenges you worked on are correct
none of the results for the challenges
are correct end of discussion
so maybe giving or like focusing on the
positive aspects of work that was being
done I don't know would change a bit the
level of frustration going on in the
field and yeah like maybe giving people
a more personalized feedback would also
encourage them to come back or go back
into the industry and not
I don't know shut them off yeah I think
um my wishes along those lines that
people will be more imaginative when it
comes to like hiring people in the sense
that young people who have candidates
with different backgrounds you know can
have a chance to you know talk about
what they can do it would also be nice
you know like I've had interviews where
people like you know they ask you to
come back three times like why and then
there and then the last interview would
be like you know it's just the CBO
asking you one question it's like what
is this for you know like they didn't
even ask for a whiteboard interview
which was frustrating cause you know you
you prepare for a pop python test and at
the end there's like a question about
like how many babies do you think will
be born in Shanghai in this year it's
like why yeah I don't know it it was it
was super strange but um anyway yeah I
mean my I've had good interviews where
people were straight to the point and I
think they were empowered by their
companies to you know you know ask
questions and make certain decisions I
would like that more to happens or like
we don't waste each other's day I don't
know if this is particular to Berlin but
just like the buzzwords in the job ads
and especially in the hiring manager is
it it's kind of annoying but also it's
it's difficult for people to break into
the field because you don't going back
to the terminology you don't know like
what your skills are and how well they
match the job and they might end up in
an interview process where it's like
clearly a mismatch and these kind of
things but I don't know if that's
particular to brillier probably just
everywhere yeah how much I just to
follow up on that how much say do you
have if you're looking to hire four team
and you need to put out a job at is it
word-for-word what you hand to the
recruiter is the recruiter giving you a
template and you're trying to update it
are they having a 10-minute conversation
with you and then writing the
description of the job based on what
they understand so I can write the job
ad any way that I want to I generally
though it's a combination
of sort of a job ad that's already
existed it's sort of to fit a company
kind of broad format and then I tailor
it to the specific job that I want and I
usually have a couple buzzwords near the
top but then get very specific very
quickly after that but some of the other
ones that I've read it's just like an AI
powered scalable machine learning
something is all you're gonna do and the
black yeah exactly
I guess I could apply for that right I
don't know okay I want to open it up to
questions if anyone has questions for
anyone on the panel if you can come down
to the side we can well first of all
thank you very helpful tips I have two
questions though first of all I'm
curious about the white boarding
interviews that you have mentioned about
what are some typical and typical
questions or problems of white boarding
interviews are those normal programming
interviews as in lead code problems you
know the code or hacking or these are
the problems that are inclined to more
data science so maybe implementing some
libraries or things like that maybe for
at least data analyst positions that
I've seen it was a lot there was a lot
of Excel SQL definitely not a lot of
Python that I've seen yeah that I think
because those were mostly business
intelligence slash and these positions
I've had Python tasks I've had SQL tasks
I've had both and I would say yes about
the level of hacker rank like the
intermediate hacker rank yes definitely
in that direction also I think some of
the companies that are interviewed with
gave me like they just copy pasted some
tasks from
[Music]
a website that hosted like whiteboard
interviews for junior developers INSCOM
right so yeah yeah I would agree also
rather like the programming related a
little bit more in the algorithmic part
something you could find in the
correcting the coding interview book
some questions like this playing dynamic
programming or something for my second
question is that what do you think some
qualities or skills that are needed for
data science professionals to be
successful in this field thank you
[Music]
probably the most important is to
actually like data science and to be
really enthusiastic about it and want to
as I was saying before I really just
develop your skills right so otherwise
you're basically gonna dead end pretty
quickly and you're just gonna hate eight
hours of your day every day right yeah
that's probably the biggest one but the
other the other one I also talked about
this and that I really stressed in the
interview process is being able to start
from some abstract problem break it down
into its component parts find out what
data you have you know and then etc
through the whole research process and
then to presenting the results for the
audience that is going to find this
information most useful so being able to
do that whole thing regardless of the
technologies of how you do it are Python
whatever is is super important
also analytical and problem-solving
skills I think are super essential and
the skill to really understand what the
actual problem is and really get behind
it and and drink dig really deep and
find the core of the problem because
sometimes it's take hold I really give
you a very rough description of the
problem and from a data science
perspective maybe the problem lies in a
very different part from what yours take
all the things it is I think it also
helps that you're open and collaborative
with other people because a lot of the
data science problems are you know
cannot be solved by just like the data
alone in my company it's all vision
you'll always see people crowding around
the computer looking at data and it's
you know people from the business side
and from you know the pure data science
side and from the from the design side
you know looking at you know what is
going on and wahby
you know what can be gleaned from it and
I think that kind of like you know being
open to perspectives it's really helpful
thank you very much for the insights I
have one question and how important do
you think cross functional knowledge is
in data science so for example I come
from a background of industrial
engineering and management so I had
engineering and at university as well as
Business and Economics and what do you
think how to approach with such a
background and to become a data
scientist do you think it's how what
what like skills also which courses are
important to do and how can somebody
with a background like mine become a
data scientist and and also has this
like different approach on looking at
data may be compared to somebody coming
from a pure informatics background
so I have background information systems
so I have other business and my studies
and I like to believe that it helps me a
lot especially at my company where we
build software for businesses and so we
try to solve business problems and it
helps a lot if you have an a deep
understanding of the domain when you do
look at the data because you don't need
to go to the main expert right away in
order to understand something that might
be in the data so I think this this is a
really big benefit for choosing Korea
with a more diverse background than just
computer science I have a background in
foreign languages and translation so for
me learning how to code was like
learning a new language like the
structure in the grammar of a new
language so when writing Python or SQL
I'm always thinking okay so this is
subject where's the predicate you know
where should I put the question mark and
so on maybe that does not answer your
exact question you know how to become a
data scientist because I'm not one but
uh definitely helps in I don't know
comparing different career paths or like
transitioning in my company because it's
a consulting data driven consulting
company so of course functionality is
important like I said the reports are
read not just by the analytics team of
our clients but also the different parts
of the company from the marketing to
their design to their say ecommerce site
for instance in terms of like what to
study I suppose I'm not I mean if I can
only speak for my case because I deal
with like social media data so I had
a lot of NLP and you know like say I
think I produce like projects and stuff
like that yeah I mean I don't know maybe
I start with something that you're
interested in because otherwise you
don't get bored and that's kind of like
variable like what Christopher's say so
I also was sort of a mixed background in
that regard I think it's hugely
important because data science as much
as we love I don't know if you love the
coding aspects or the math or whatever
it
for understanding problems answering
questions and giving us hopefully some
insights in terms of some some problem
that we have so having the substantive
background can help you really
understand the problem and formulate an
answer and understand what the data is
telling you in a way that I mean I guess
you could do if you didn't have that
background but it would be a lot much
slower and laborious process another
thing that's really funny is that often
often times having the substantive
background will help you practically in
your data science so a lot of times
members of my team have presented their
work and they'll put up a graph and
they're like I spent like two weeks
trying to figure out why the heck this
number is this way and they'll present
it to somebody who has the domain
knowledge and though and the person with
the domain knowledge will go oh yeah it
was because of this one thing maybe they
knew right away right and so it was it
because the person doing the analysis
didn't have that domain knowledge they
thought it was a data problem but it was
actually there is information in the
data they just didn't understand because
they didn't have the knowledge to
understand it maybe to add what concrete
skills you could could build so being
like fairly fluent in programming helps
getting the basic data tools right like
pandas and numpy and so on helps having
a solid background in statistical
methods and basic machine learning
methods this should be all like a given
skill set a stack of skills one should
have and on top of that one depending on
what you're interested in if you want to
go in a specific domain like an LP then
you can start learning more about this
but like having like programming skills
like knowing the basic libraries in
Python this is I think the skill set one
definitely needs other questions yeah
thanks again for the insights for me I
just wanted maybe to follow follow up on
one of the questions before regarding
the educational background so from a
hiring managers perspective how would
you rate the importance of having a
master's degree or PhD and also compared
to like having like actual professional
experience so I would actually read it
pretty highly but I think it's important
to understand why I'm reading it pretty
highly it's because somebody who's done
a masters or PhD typically has had a lot
of opportunities to develop a research
project and get in the details etc but
it's not it's by far not the only place
that you could get that right so it's an
indicator of someone who could do that
and then I try to dig down with them
into what exactly did you do during your
master's degree or PhD but you could
have that experience in another way
either through kind of industry
experience working in open source
working for data-driven NGOs things like
that also could could definitely get
that as well
I think I want to add to that question
just whether you think to the group
whether you think it's different in
Berlin job market than in other parts of
Germany if you're applying for data
rules with or without the masters or the
PhD so for the original question I'm I'm
a hiring manager but for my personal
opinion and my personal experience with
working with the people around me I
would great professional experience
fairly highly because certain things
just work really well if you work with
people that have like on-the-job
practical experience but for certain
tasks you definitely need this this
research mind I think and yeah then it's
really difficult to somehow show if you
don't have a academic backgrounds but
the other question is for which jobs do
you actually need this for which data
related positions do you need this and I
think they're more companies require
this then actually would need it then to
the balloon question this is just a gut
feeling that I have is that in Berlin
it's a little bit less formal because
it's a bit more international and less
German I would say I have the feeling
that traditionally in Greater Germany
you have a bigger focus on on formal
qualifications but just my gut feeling I
don't have a very big experience with
that
so I think this is partially a German
thing but I've seen it in under other
industries so I used to do a lot of work
with people in finance and they view
certain teams I think in data science or
in the finance example as like a
prestige team right and so they are
almost trying the expectation is that
you would have a team with people with
high qualifications because this is your
prestige team and it's kind of goofy I
would have to say overall and it's
probably going to be a waste of money
from management's perspective but that
is definitely a problem but I would also
not want to work on such a team because
you're you're just setting yourself up
for frustration right so these people
view it as you know you're gonna have
the AI whatever future and then you get
into the details of you know we don't
actually have the data it answers quit
but that's kind of stuff and it'll just
lead to disappointment so I would avoid
those situations also as someone who is
applying for positions so avoid the
situation of having lots and lots of
academics slash PhDs and the prestige
team kind of pedigree I wouldn't say
avoid that I would I would say avoid a
situation avoid situations where that
team exists because not because it was
they had specific needs that those
people addressed but because those
people where the need was having a
prestige team and those people have PhDs
so avoid that situation so in other
words ask people if they actually use
their academic credentials on the job
okay other questions
you are all great but my question is for
Oliva you said that you need been during
your business interviews you said that
you would need as a junior mentorship
and help to grow further so have you
changed this attitude to get more
positive results or did have you have
you kept saying that during the
interviews yeah I kept saying that I
kept saying that because none of them
said oh no we cannot offer you that we
expect you to be like
self-organized and you know we expected
to do this and that from day one because
because this is how we do it everyone
every interviewer said that yes of
course mentorship is available you know
help we do have like the entire team the
entire team of seniors is like here to
help you so yeah I kept saying that
because this is what I was going for I
needed I needed guidance you know
because I I hadn't worked I didn't I
never worked in a company where I would
be so involved in the business flow
right my previous job is all concerned
you know very I know artificial doing so
you know not not going deep into the
infrastructure of the company right
whereas now I'm like getting
responsibilities you know when the
server is down I'm the one who has to
switch it on so yeah
more questions all right
thank you very much to all our panelists
and thank you to Valentina for
organizing the panel
[Applause]